[Musique]
à toute première expérience d'acteur à
fâcheuse nouvelle pour un corps pur et
dur extrémités où je me vois réduit tu
viens sylvestre d'apprendre au port que
mon père revient oui qu'il arrive ce
matin mal ce matin même après je crois
que
si je pense du petit garçon ces derniers
de sarda qui m'a qui n'avait pourtant
mais à quelques scènes une admiration
une fascination même pour trouver pour
cet homme qui me faisait un peu peur
isabelle adjani par exemple je suis une
trêve impératrice
[Musique]
c'était belmondo s'était de funès les
grands acteurs populaires et ensuite
michel serrault encore maintenant ils me
quitte pas j'étais assez fasciné par des
acteurs de comédie
didier bourdon par exemple entre 13 et
20 ans j'ai une sorte de monomanie sur
jean-louis barrault
j'ai fait du théâtre très petit avec ma
voisine à ouagadougou
quelque chose de relier directement à
l'enfant ce qui est jouée à faire comme
si
le fait d'être au français s'était même
avis mon but
[Musique]
chivu les deux trois jours entre des
sessions de répèt comini française pour
la reprise de don juan
pour venir ici pour présenter le film
d'arnaud desplechin la forêt qu'on a
tourné à partir de la pièce d'autres au
ski
dernière maintenant été présenté ce soir
si valve du film
[Applaudissements]
la comédie française
iron will enjoy the movie police actuel
5e match tu sais que je suis un
fortunato of lost et en suis très
content au mieux donc du ca qui tu es à
faire un acteur de province donc tu ne
sais pas dommage je te paye du plomb
dans la tête c'est dans les anciens
temps que la force physique a fait la
merde qu'est ce que tu veux génial armes
à feu avec toi non j'aime les moyens
naturels en quoi puis-je vous être utile
c'est un peu exceptionnel ici pour le
film dans un joli français dignes
enfants
on y rencontre du théâtre en iran parce
que c'est un des plus beaux outils de
théâtre lice en france qui dix ans
arrivé lundi à 13 heures sur le plateau
pour donjons en pleine forme dans la
région
[Musique]
ce qu'ils ont
le 1000 m da
[Musique]
mais tous les deux ensemble mais on
contacte avec
oui mais tu me l'avait dit ce n'est pas
un prix mais qu'est ce qu'on fait on
continue quand même tu veux qu'on soit
lié à demeurer aux premiers objets qui
nous prend qu'on renonce au monde pour
lui qu'on n'est plus dieu merci c'est
marrant parce que quand tu rentres ici
un petit peu l'idée il ya un peu une
idée mystérieuse de cette maison et puis
il y avait aussi moins de gens qui me
dit oui mais c'est le côté un peu nantis
c'est à dire il faut une pièce il disait
alexandre un pouvoir non mais moi quand
je suis rentré j'avais ça en tête mais
j'ai tellement changé d'avis et j'ai
jamais vu des gens bosser autant la
comédie-française moi c'est un endroit
qui me convient très bien parce que oui
la frénésie parfois le travail dans
laquelle on peut être et dans laquelle
on est toujours moi elle mes lectrices
tu connais tellement d'acteurs et
d'actrices magnifique qui ne veulent pas
ou qui n'ont pas voulu travailler comme
ça qui sont partis je pense à marina ans
audrey bonnet et qui tout d'un coup se
sont dit non moi j'ai besoin de temps ce
qui me faisait rêver
c'était le lieu la troupe et
qu'heureusement l'alternance soit les
trois piliers les trois choses me fait
vraiment rêver
l'alternance de pouvoir rejouer un jour
molière shakespeare ou à contemporain en
étant ici j'ai j'ai accès à un éventail
deux possibilités de répertoire que je
n'aurais pas ailleurs feydeau voltaire
shakespeare gogol j'aurais pas pu jouer
ce à l'extérieur sur un temps aussi
réduit avec une troupe de cette qualité
cette souplesse là je pense qu'elle
qu'elle sert au cinéma mais elle sert
tous les acteurs un acteur tout ça
travaille plus à jour nous veilleurs c
est un plaisir du challenge je trouve
qu'ils ont l'habitude d'être distribué
d'être de faire des seconds rôles des
premiers rôles de bras ces deux
rencontres ennemis metteur en scène
[Musique]
tout est bien qu'un décès puisque je
suis votre pays je suis grand coup hier
siphonnant moi c'est tous ceux qui sont
de rambouillet voilà n'importe où elles
le peuvent un franc mais je l'europe il
ya quelquefois des choses qu'on ne peut
pas faire à l'extérieur veut pas faire
certains films ne peut pas faire parce
que on joue le soir et que on vous
demande d'être je dis n'importe quoi
mais
au brésil pendant un mois a dit ben non
là je joue je suis dans l'alternance je
peux pas faire ce film quand on est
acteur dans cette maison on se doit de
consacrer notre temps en exclusivité à
ce qui se passe dans cette maison je
savais en rentrant ici que ça allait me
rendre indisponible pour d'autres choses
mais ça me rend pas indisponible pour
rien j'ai des choses sublimes en échange
donc tout va bien mais j'essaie au
niveau des plannings c'est compliqué
mais moi je fais toujours tout pour pour
que ça marche il était au point mort
vous êtes trop vite
parce que
[Musique]
hong kong chez l'isolément c'est hyper
important je suis désolé monsieur allô
oui
non pas du tout ça va plus les acteurs
travaillent et l'extérieur plus ils
ramènent de joie de sciences
d'expérience donc c'est bien ça s'est
fait de tout temps encore une fois la
comédie française a accompagné édition
du cinéma depuis le cinéma muet depuis
la création du cinéma a été lun à jeu
chaque étape d'une manière ininterrompue
dès ses premiers mouvements dans la
nivelle le cinéma films les acteurs de
la comédie-française en 1900 la grande
sarah bernhardt est la première à
tourner dans le duel dame l'est
ouvrant ainsi la voie à pierre fresnay
madeleine renaud
louis seigner
ou encore pierre dux sous l'impulsion
des 1000 femmes en 1935 la comédie
française s'engage dans la voie du
cinéma et commence à produire ses
propres films
une implication sans cesse innover
colonnes soliveau par le seul appui
jambe à traves top paire de griffes
verrou serrure tuiles pierre l'enfer
plâtre simon peinture marbre vert kabuye
coup perd en salles sombres grenier
office cabinet terrasses escaliers
cinéma de temps en temps j'aime beaucoup
maintenir le plus longtemps ce qui
marche
donc on épuise le filon jusqu'au
jusqu'au bout de la mine quoi et j'ai
quelquefois l'impression qu'il ya des
époques où on se méfiait beaucoup de
ceux qui savent dire le texte dont on
comprend chaque syllabe et sacs qu'on
sonne parfois ce sont les contraintes de
la maison qui poussent aux diverses
certains comédiens décide de quitter la
troupe par exemple isabelle adjani
philippe torreton
annie girardot ou marina pense au choix
zee de reprendre leur liberté
un choix que gisèle casadesus ce n'est
jamais voulu faire et pourtant en 1934 à
peine entré à la comédie française
elle se laisser séduire par la caméra
j'ai eu la chance de tourner mon premier
film est d'obtenir donc mon congé au
théâtre français à peine entré pour
tourner un film avec marcel l'herbier et
d'un grand metteur en scène de l'époque
et j'ai tourné ce film qui s'appelait
l'aventurier avec victor france aisne
qui était le grand jeune premier aussi
de ces années là
mais après je n'ai pu tourner avant
longtemps parce que je n'obtenais pas de
congé je jouais beaucoup et je n'avais
pas la possibilité de tourner moi j'ai
pas regretter c'est comme ça bon mon
chemin c'était le théâtre et la comédie
française le cinéma c'était bien ça me
mervin c'était secondaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce que
[Musique]
c
le moment de saluer avec toute la troupe
on sait tous la main et les gens
applaudissent et après infarctus à lui
dans cette salle qui porte quand même
300 de 30 ans d'histoire
il se passe quelque chose ça fait
vraiment son effet l'impression de faire
partie de quelque chose
y'a vraiment ce set chose d'être tout le
temps confrontés au mythe en fait quand
on me propose un rôle parfois il a été
marquée par des acteurs qui sont encore
dans la troupe
et ça c'est donc toujours deux sortes de
défis vraiment lié au mythe à la légende
[Musique]
le théâtre de molière le théâtre de
molière avec le fauteuil de molière qui
est dans le fruit des êtres et puis
surtout de au delà de ça une troupe
permanente
l'esprit de troupe c'est une richesse
parce qu'il ya 60 acteurs qui ont des
formations très différentes qui ont eu
des maîtres très différents qui ont des
expériences très différentes
donc d'un côté une espèce d'altérité
folle cumulée comme ça et puis d'un
autre côté quand il ya un danger ou un
coup de solidarité à avoir il ya une
espèce d'euphorie qui se crée comme ça
souvent impressionnés par le mouvement
commun vers un espèce de même but
artistique
on a une troupe d'alternance la vedette
c'est la comédie française que les
médias mettent en avant certains actes
or c'est très bien aussi ces gens là
même du public c'est très bien une
troupe
ce qui est magnifique c'est que l'on
peut travailler tous les jours on peut
travailler sur un instrument comme un
musicien tous les jours ici le chemin
avec la troupe pour moi le plus
important que l'institution serre si un
jour à la troupe décide de déménager
conduit soit tu continues à jouer aux
français mais c'est un test national
soit tu vas avec la troupe n'hésite pas
une seconde que je vous file avec la
troupe dans la seconde s'est passé oui
c'est le travail à 4 ou moi qui me
motive ma plus grande douleur si je pars
d'ici un jour cesser de quitter la
troupe et ça je le ressens très fort en
ce moment où je tourne toute la semaine
et de revenir ici là comme aujourd'hui
pour répéter un samedi ça fait du bien
de
revenir le week-end dans la famille il
ya un moule louis peut-être qui se fait
une façon de jouer ensemble depuis
longtemps donc une habitude des réflexes
à se retrouver les uns les autres biens
état d'esprit une rapidité et une
vélocité dernière fois qu on s'était vus
tous les deux tu jouais les amants
qu'est ce que tu as fait après mon lieu
après je suis passé comique mais là
aussi les comics qui prolifèrent art
déco mais je suis tombé souffleur ce que
ça peut être 50 ans dans la mi-août un
souffleur soir comme à montréal connaît
un petit bonhomme de chemin qu'on avait
même fernand bar le soc est simple faire
le pitre c'est pas sorcier
mais et c'est un peu les tragiques là
y'a plus personne
ils ont l'intelligence du texte
c'est à dire que le rapport aux textes
ils posent toujours les bonnes questions
pourquoi comment qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est-ce que ça ouvre qu'est-ce que ça
ferme comme porte donc ils ont un
rapport au texte qui est extrêmement
présent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qui a joué appareils là par exemple
dans lucrèce borgia j'avais une scène
avec eric ruf qui duré 40 minutes
c'est inenvisageable si on ne sait pas
pourquoi on vit n'importe comment
et on est contentes la journée se
termine non pour voir plongé dans le
sommeil c'est ennuyeux mais question de
savoir pourquoi ils apprennent leur
texte c'est même un préjugé parce que
moi ça m'est arrivé d'aller sur un
plateau qui savaient pas un mot de texte
mais on me prêtait de toute façon une
sorte science infuse du texte ce qui
fait qu'on me pardonne et ne pas savoir
et les gens se sont pas rendu compte que
je ne connaissais pas mon texte j'étais
en train de l'apprendre au fil des
prises ça fait partie des comédiens qui
viennent pas vous expliquer ce que ce
que vous avez écrit mais qui viennent
vous révéler des des couleurs un peu
différente des quelquefois vous
surprendre
[Musique]
ces derniers temps
vu perdu l'oeil alors toujours fous de
merde
tout ce qu'on reproche aux acteurs de
théâtre diction grandiloquente
une manière de se regarder jouer
c'est c'est très souvent je m'aperçois
que ce sont des chants qui ne vont
jamais au téléski qui conservent dans
leur tête des idées préconçues qui
pensaient tous ces généraux qui serait
buts et 80 mm en vingt minutes
tout le monde s'est battu tout le monde
non pas tout le monde tu es un tic dans
le tas quand toute la tranche est appuyé
sur la gâchette n'importe qui peut faire
ça les bombes les canons les
mitrailleuses la mort à l'aveuglette
n'importe qui peut donc y aller au
couteau on y voyait blanc de l'oeil aux
frères ayant crevé karl pas lui qui
tiendrait contre un train blindé tout
frais lâchait l'idée d'être rentré d'un
coup de surin tu es un type en foutant
la verte à tout le régiment c'est ça le
vrai boulot et on se laisse happer nous
hâter 3000 type et c'est nous qui
l'avons gagnée cette [__] de guerre
d'où des 3000 les autres les autres ils
ont fait entre 20 et 25 ans où je
sortais du du conservatoire et j'avais
le sentiment que les acteurs de cinéma
c'était des animaux sauvages et que les
acteurs de théâtre c'était des animaux
domestiques et tout le prestige est
évidemment du côté de l'animal sauvage
et que l'acteur de théâtre c'est un bon
chien chien qui faisait exactement là on
lui disait de de faire et j'avais
l'impression que par nature
j'appartenais avec catégorie domestique
cinéma me semblait toujours plus petits
plus je comprenais pas très bien comment
ça fonctionnait tout ça et ça a été
vraiment une découverte ou l2
en plus de passer du théâtre au cinéma
si ma fenêtre je veux près de mon amant
aujourd'hui réd de tes pleurs carrément
puisant te foutra dollars si nos pas et
[Musique]
c'était très beau je veux voir ce lien
découvrir le cinéma c'est la première
fois que guité film et celui adoré voir
des gens de cinéma regarder ce film
c'est un an mais en fait ils sont
vachement moins voilà ce dégoût qui a dû
théâtre qui serait là lui aussi visé qui
serait la mort et le cinéma qui serait
la vie alors que voilà sais c'est pas
vrai
raconter la vie je me suis retrouvé dans
un parking avec des haches je devais
démolir une jaguar
on faisait des céréales james bond de la
nuit sur les toits et là je me suis dit
ça je pourrais pas le faire au théâtre
par exemple est donc là je je me suis
rendu compte que si les espaces change
le cadre change mais c'est c'est le même
métier quoi ballantyne caillou à une
très jolie nuque
valentine cailloux dit des mots comme
nonobstant ou encore péricliter alors
tim k you me parle toujours quand elle
se brosse les dents mais bizarrement je
la comprends toujours que j'irai demain
14 avril la passerelle entre le théâtre
et le cinéma parfois en france allait
compliquer quand tu penses que ian
mckellen il joue gandalf et dans x men
et le lendemain il joue un beckett dans
un tout petit théâtre battue dit bah
ouais la passerelle elle est évidente et
tu vas pas dire ian mckellan [__] au
théâtre quand il va au cinéma enfin je
crois que l'adaptation c'est une grande
qualité d'acteur
donc je crois que quand on s'adapte à un
metteur en scène un projet une pièce de
théâtre ou un film est bas et basse à
chaque fois c'est une nouvelle
définition forcément parce que c'est pas
le même scénario se perd même histoire
c'est pas la même façon de travailler
par exemple
68 repreneur là quand on dit théâtre
cinéma je sais pas quoi jeu pour moi
c'est aucune différence en fait ça a
lieu où ça n'a pas lieu les rencontres
se font de part on est heureux ou pas
[Musique]
oh
tiens
sorgues a relaté beaucoup il a encore
besoin de quelques corrections de 10 des
fois on est plus interprète déforme
complètement créateurs parfois on se
retrouve à instrumentaliser avec les
limites qu'il faut donner à ça aussi
tout est prêt puis je cherchais un grand
luxe détracteurs voilà c'est boxé du
travail un peu mais ça c'est un très
grand luxe d'avoir la chance de côtoyer
des très grands textes je parle pour le
théâtre ou des rencontres humaines au
cinéma des artistes vraiment qu'ils ont
un point de vue sur le monde qui ont
envie de raconter une histoire d'être
clown dans cette histoire amuseur
saltimbanques je le vois comme ça je
sais ça un acteur très rarement un
artiste pour moi mais voilà à d'amuseur
[Musique]
nous c'est jamais gagné un mariage c'est
une aventure un mariage même après peu
réussissent la fidélité pas facile
facile hein ça non vous allez vous unit
aujourd'hui pour le meilleur parfois
pour le pire
car vous savez la vie de couple c'est
pas folichon folichon bateau se
rapproche du musicien interprète sauf
que le musicien et son instrument sont
confondus
c'est la même personne c'est le corps et
c'est un métier en plus on n'existe pas
sans les autres c'est pas un acteur tout
seul dans sa chambre
est ce que c'est vraiment un acteur
économique qui ne sait pas s'il reste
dans sa chambre et ne l'est jamais pour
un moment de fête devant une assemblée
et se soumettre au suffrage de cette
assemblée
c'est le moment de gêne pas je vais le
zoo mais paris vraiment louis jouvet
disais c'est le real c'est comme les
choix tout le cimetière quand faut y
aller faut y aller
je suppose que les gâteaux sont
angoissés les bd garceau mais bon quoi
sert votre foi en dieu doit l'aider
la peur d'affronter le monde numérique
moi ce qui me donne le trail comme même
au cinéma c'est des spectateurs qui sont
derrière la caméra je sais que au cinéma
le traquer et je le ressens tu du
manière très différente qu'au théâtre au
théâtre je les eaux au début du
spectacle très fort il est à se flinguer
mais une fois que c'est parti c'est
parti sur un plateau de cinéma c'est un
peu plus compliqué j'ai le trac à chaque
prise à chaque prise de chaque séquence
chaque séquence de chaque c'est donc ça
fait beaucoup de trac dans une seconde
et c'est pas un truc d'intello la
philosophie l'ispa de la masturbation
intellectuelle
c'est un sport de combat un art martial
c'est la meilleure façon de passer c'est
manipuler ne pas laisser vendre des
goûts notre cerveau à des marchands de
limonade de fringues de montre peu
importe ce qui n'empêche pas d'aimer les
freins ou les montres mais ça permet de
comprendre ce qu'on fait pourquoi c'est
important d'être conscient de ce qu'on
fait est réveillé tout le temps la
philosophie une libération elle libère
l'homme de son inclination parce qu'elle
libère sa pensée et une pensée libre et
irréductible je suis persuadé que d'être
sur une scène devant une assistance à
nespouls fondamentalement pas naturel et
donc il faut un temps de préparation
pour ça pour habituer son propre record
à être sous le regard de tous
par trois mois je souhait public moby
voir ça la répétition c'est fait pour
que ce moment non naturelles soient de
plus en plus naturel soit acceptée par
le corps tout entier au cinéma tu
répètes pas forcément beaucoup une scène
alors que ça va être potentiellement vu
par 5 millions de personnes
alors qu'au théâtre tu va répéter
peut-être deux mois sur neuf réplique
pour qu'au bout du compte nous 1000 ou
1500 personnes le voir yves qu'est ce
qui se passe ici je dessine des signes
pour ne pas entendre
faut que je tienne pas entendre quoi
écrire le silence c'est pareil c'est
toujours pareil depuis le début il est
toujours pareil calme toi et je suis
trop court je suis le talent tu là le
reste je m'en occupe une actrice là que
j'ai même croisé la maison qui est
vraiment une jardinière
c'est à dire que les répétitions départ
elle plantes graines mais le tuteur et
petit à petit on arrose et on voit
comment ça pousse pour laisser la chose
s'épanouir cette méthode est applicable
au théâtre elle n'est pas aussi le voyez
je vous prie d'agréer l'assurance de la
considération la plus distinguée la
bohème allons transférer la
considération la plus distinguée autre
chose
pourquoi êtes vous parti ce matin de
chardons donc c est bien ça nous dire
adieu vous dormiez les acteurs de cinéma
plus ils font du cinéma plus ce sont des
enfants gâtés
hélas cette chose d'enfant gâté y avait
pas et le travail était été
très respecté et c'est ça c'est
extrêmement émouvant et très troublant
je me suis dit waouh on est vraiment
quand on fait du cinéma mon nez on les
fout on arrive en retard ou moi même moi
quand je fais l'actrice jeu
j'ai mon portable entre chaque fois
c'est fou il sait tout ça n'existait pas
j'ai toujours eu peur qu'au cinéma on
travaille pas assez
enfin le jeu d'acteur et pas forcément
au centre et j'aime tellement travaillé
tellement tellement cherché reprendre me
perdre bon je suis pas du tout efficace
à du tout et genre en plus je refuse
d'agir quand on me le demande de seine
c'est vraiment une souffrance et je sais
qu'il faut que j'apprenne voilà c'est
pas grave hein des fois il faut produire
quelque chose tout de suite c'est
souvent des acteurs qui veulent toujours
aller plus loin et que au cinéma il ya
toujours le d'abord il ya l'efficacité
de l'immédiat donc la superficialité
d'une certaine façon est aussi le temps
il faut aller vite ça coûte cher et
c'est donc on réduit de plus en plus
dans le temps de tournage le temps de
recherche de temps de travail avec avec
l'acteur quand vous voulez c'est un
ébéniste du faubourg saint antoine qui
les fabriquent
[Musique]
avec ça tu veux en b to b
je
et au théâtre
on revient chaque soir sur sur sa toile
donc on peut remettre un petit peu de
bleu là un petit peu de vert là jusqu'à
la dernière représentation
et ce qui est intéressant et c'est
important c'est de ne pas faire
exactement la même chose parce que aussi
les mains c'est ça qui se passe c'est
qu'on revient chez soi dans cela refait
la scène peut plus rien faire
bien sûr fait ça fait super bien c'est
parfait mais terrible assez génial mais
on est très très bon et on dit pourquoi
je n'ai pas fait ça pourquoi mais c'est
trop tard
par exemple premier jour de tournage
hier pour moi j'ai tourné la scène qui
est la scène de basculement amoureux
s'étaient premier jour d'action
il a fallu traverser tout ce qui s'est
passé avant mais vraiment comme on le
fait au théâtre le travailleur c'est
vraiment de vivre
mais quand on n'a pas répété donc soit
c'est par l'imagination
soit c'est par le travail que me
travaille beaucoup ils ont énormément de
pièces
chaque année ils atteignent une espèce
de perfection de la technique de jeu et
qui approche le le maître jedi de du jeu
et de la comédie
[Musique]
le tournage moi j'ai besoin d'y penser
tout le temps je suis un personnage
principal je suis un personnage pas
pousser vraiment qui je suis mais mais
je veux dire je suis dans cet univers là
tout le temps du tournage
alors qu'au théâtre non c'est la
représentation faut plonger ici
maintenant
au moment où entre en scène écoute c'est
pas parce que ton frère a essayé de
noyer est obligé de mettre dans des
états pareils à toute attente nous
attend pour dîner des fêtes est balisé
va changer tu vas pas restés tout les
vacances on y parle non plus hein je
trouve que ce qui est dur au cinéma
c'est le sait la rétention
c'est le le minimalisme
d'être à la fois dans le dans le
contrôle et en même temps de laisser la
place au moment au moment de grâce au
vent qui vont nous échappent et qui
seront capturés et immortalisée par une
caméra que savez je n'ai pas dit lofalk
qu'est ce que vous lui donnez n'ai pas
dit qu avec mademoiselle julie vous vous
disputiez s'ouvre et que l'autre soit
faisait passer des choses
pourquoi vous l'avez pas dit je l'avais
raté
je leur ai dit mon opération pas lieu
alors à faire s'il peut nous protéger
arrête je n'ai pas besoin j'ai rien à me
reprocher le cadre technique du théâtre
n'est pas le même que la maîtrise qu'on
va demander au cinéma l'acteur a
beaucoup plus de responsabilités qu au
cinéma dans le sens oui c'est lui qui
fait l'espace en fait c'est lui qui crée
l'espace cédule sur lui que repose la
règle le rythme de la pièce des scènes
au cinéma on demande plus une l'acteur
de fournir une matière et le montage va
venir donner le rythme finale de la
scène sur un plateau de théâtre en
général on à la répétition on a le
travail en amont c'est à dire que les
meubles on les connaît le texte on le
connaît cinéma on arrivait avant qu'on
tourne une scène cinq minutes avant nous
mais des rails de travelling trois
perches les quatre projets dans les yeux
et vas-y abandonne toi ça c'est pas
simple on est là il ya un scotch au sol
il ya vingt personnes qui sont là et qui
vous regardent et maquillage tak tak et
la caméra est là et puis on regarde le
scotch qui est là sur la caméra et
actions ça c'est quand même s'il faut
arriver
imagination à alex 502 sur un arrière de
terrain alors qu'est-ce que puis après
il ya la technique qui s'apprend c'est
comment on fait avec les raccords avec
une scène qui dure de 3 minutes 4
minutes cinq minutes mais qu'on tourne
sur toute une journée avec des raccords
d'humeur entre 9h du matin et six ou
sept heures le soir
voilà ça c'est une technique d'acteur de
cinéma qui est pas qu'ils aient pas
donner ça s'apprend c'est l'expérience
il ya deux gamins dans mon école de
gammal vous voulez privés de cantine
j'en fais quoi dans ça commence
aujourd'hui avec bertrand
je me souviens on est arrivé le matin il
m'a demandé tu sais ton texte oui on
avait une grande scène avec philippe
torreton et il m'a dit tu veux pas nous
montrer un peu ce que tu ce que tu me
proposes ya trop de familles qu'à plus
de la situation et le cas dans beaucoup
d'argent mais vous n'êtes pas atteint
balle près ont fait des centaines de
fois ça fait une somme les familles ça
fait cinq mois que nous donne pas tiqué
chaque mois qu'on nourrit leurs enfants
pratiquement je suis pas toujours les
plus démunis et des mondes qui bouffent
pas ça fait quoi je n'ai pas de leçon à
recevoir de vous c'est d'abord les cinq
acteurs de théâtre c'est que je sais que
je peux avec eux faire des plans très
long parce que ils sont habitués à
affronter
des longs passages de textes j'ai un
taux de 34 % de chômeurs dans cette
commune nous sortons d'une tutelle
économiques causés par mon prédécesseur
alors la solution j'aimerais bien
l'avoir plus d'un car mon budget passe
dans l'action sociale vous n'êtes pas
seuls ici seul huit écoles comme la
vôtre et plus d'argent vient pas de
boulot des entreprises qui ont fermé les
unes après les autres je me bats pour
qu'on soit en zep
j'ai écrit au ministre plusieurs fois
toujours pas ce que je dois faire avec
les enfants que les parents prennent
leur responsabilité c'est une grande
scène et on a fait ça mais bon comme ça
parce qu'on est deux acteurs de théâtre
et donc quoi la scène s'est passée et
tout le monde a applaudi quoi c'était
donc c'était sympa
dans une scène qui demandait beaucoup
beaucoup d'énergie je voulais pas faire
n'était des dizaines de prises
on a réussi à trouver trouver des places
de caméras nous on suivait les gens
passer de l'un à l'autre et je pouvais à
ce moment-là garder l'énergie qu'ils
avaient tous les deux dans le plan
action
[Musique]
à la limite un acteur complètement
génial comme harvey keitel était était
quelqu'un qui ne comprenait rien au
problème d'objectifs de place de caméras
une chose comme ça j'ai jamais eu ce
problème avec avec avec philippe
torreton ou samuel le bihan la technique
est importante pour moi au théâtre et au
cinéma jeux justement toujours au
réalisateur ou à la réalisatrice on est
on est à combien alors il ya certains
qui disent maintenant ça te regarde pas
tu joues comme d'habitude bah oui mais
non j'ai pas d'accord si vous êtes sur
un grand écran et que vous êtes comme ça
si vous faites ça au lieu de faire ça si
vous faites ça il faut c'est pas pareil
ça rien à voir
[Musique]
aussi non pas un gros blanc fait que moi
mon visage réagit différemment
j'ai des picotements fait des petites
manifestations nerveuse que je n'ai pas
au théâtre
elles prennent tout le corps parce que
je suis surtout parce que je suis venu
de plus loin en permanence et qui a pas
cet effet de rapprochement de montage de
caméras un proche j'ai encore beaucoup
de mal à me voir à l'écran j'ai pas pris
cinq mois au théâtre on sera on se
regarde très peu
je pense qu'on joue toujours pour la
caméra et du coup ça c'est peu troublant
c'est un peu eux mêmes parfois
dérangeant de façon d'être voir miroir
tout le temps est de savoir ce qu'on
fait et de dire si je fais ça et si je
fais ça si je fais ça et du coup parfois
c'est un peu moi ça m'a un peu troublé
le rapport à l'ego que c'est de toujours
penser à ce qu'on fait à son image
j'ai le nom d'un des héros des simpson
et les comment la smit heures ça dedans
il écoule jaillit ponctuelles
professionnelle quel genre de type quoi
havas tu veux smithers ce2a référence en
matière de lâche qui fuit
c'est à dire elle le gars c'est un son
bien
ils adorent ces rues minées par son boss
le gars est une merde mais une eau
d'abord j'ai compris je vois les
premiers films où je sens je veux
maîtriser les choses à jeu a qu'au
théâtre al haq legros et j'ai dû me sens
que j'ai toujours conscience qu'il ya un
oeil qui en train de
de me regarder de au scalpel j'ai mis du
temps à oublier ça en même temps n'étant
pas du que ça tourne quand même donc
c'est toujours le grand paradoxe de la
maîtrise et de l'abandon c'est take et
l'oeil de la caméra qui est une machine
une machine habité et ça c'est pas
facile pas naturel je trouve que c'est
moins naturel que de monter sur une
scène avec mathieu j'ai jamais pensé
qu'il y avait une caméra dans l'espace
dans lequel on évolue et en fait il nous
est complètement oublié
la caméra c'est quand j'ai vu le travail
que je me suis dit dès qu'il m'a vu
comme at il pris la fuite
ce n'est pas la nuit les rois en font
tout autant chez moi si ce grand bruit
qui court de vaud merveilles a trompé
mon esprit en frappant de voir et pour
le témoigner choisissez en quel lieu il
vous plaît de rayer le produit des
bateaux ce bras toujours vainqueur je ne
vais pas renier que je suis votre coeur
des contraintes propres au cinéma qui
sont les marques les rythmes un jeu plus
psychologique je dirais plus réaliste
c'était vachement bien mais ne voilà les
encombrer d'obligations physique c'est
toujours très bon quand on a des choses
à faire avec les mains et le corps n'a
pas la sensation de jouer quelque chose
vous échappe
il ya une confiance totale qui doit être
faite au réalisateur à l'équipe à
l'objet on accepte d'être volée
complètement et il faut il faut accepter
d'être volé tout bégaiement toutes roues
de texte
trébuchement accident tout ça vraiment
c'est benni mc terre de théâtre il doit
tenir une ligne sur parfois un an de
représentation donc il ya un contrôle
quasi absolu sur un plateau de cinéma va
falloir qu'il accepte il va falloir lui
faire donner voilà un peu un peu de lui
qui ne contrôlera pas un acteur qui
contrôle tout et pas un bon acteur je
pense où ça peut être un bon acteur mais
ça sera pas un grand acteur la seule
solution c'est d'être à la fois dans le
souci de bien faire bien à prendre ton
texte d'avoir bien travaillé savoir
pourquoi tu es là et vouloir que la
scène marche le mieux possible entre
nous et tout ça et en même temps t'en
[__] de pas mal de choses c'est-à-dire
faut en [__] que chaque minute coup de
20000 euros parce que si tu pense à ça
c'est foutu il faut te [__]
effectivement obtenir [__] on tourne
maintenant ça se trouve c'est que une
prise ou deux et basta et ce sera dans
les noeuds sur les écrans partout en
france faute en foot de ça
[Musique]
ça peut aussi la drogue l'affiché du ghb
impossible déjà elle était partie si si
ça pose à moitié à poil et puis un
clochard barbu qui le met sa langue dans
la bouche
ouais faut dire que truc positif c'est
que c'était pas à tf1
merci vous pouviez je suis désolé c'est
un peu comme le sport le théâtre même le
cinéma ça à voir avec le sport c'est
très important ça je trouve que c'est
une notion pour moi primordial c'est à
dire que c'est physique tout ça
au cinéma on convoque pas la même
intensité musculaire on parlait pas au
même volume
on se tient pas de la même manière au
niveau de son corps parce que on n'a pas
à projeter non seulement la voix mais
les émotions quand la caméra est au près
comme un musée du cd&v je crois moi tu
crois tu sais je sais que c'est
atrocement fois est ce que tu aimes
judith
ouais
et puis quand
je pourrais en minutes seulement
donc vous êtes ensemble
espérons qu'il y une seconde j'ai dit
sur ce thème là une soeur cachée quelque
part tu crois quand vous êtes tout en
retenue toute une journée de tournage
sur un rôle précis et que le soir vous
êtes en train de décupler vos forces
en fait c'est comme si vous aviez retenu
toute la journée quelque chose et puis
que le soir vous pouvez lâcher les
chevaux quoi en fait le théâtre on est
beaucoup plus autonome
les acteurs sont beaucoup plus hauteur
de ce qui se passe au cinéma avec la
caméra il faut consentir à n'être qu'un
élément qu un instrument parmi d'autres
et même pas l'essentiel l'essentiel je
sais pas ce que c'est l'essentiel je me
demande si c'est pas la lumière
je me demande si c'est pas le montage ça
peut être frustrant et une fois passée
cette frustration il faut justifier
d'accepter s'abandonner à ça sachant qu
il arrive parfois que l'on était
magnifique souvenir du tournage et qu'à
l'arrivée on a parlé ce même pas dans le
film
ça peut arriver alors le radical ces
cordons bleus plus de steak haché mais
c'est dans la même petite à la grande
fête mais j'ai très faim mais je veux
plutôt que la rôtisserie le cinéma tout
nous échappe à partir du moment où on a
tourné les scènes elles peuvent être
sublimé ou totalement ruinés par le
montage par tout ce qui va être ajoutée
par tout ce qu'on contrôle plus alors
que au théâtre le rideau se lève et là
c'est le c'est le royaume des acteurs le
cinéma c'est toujours fragmenté on
tourne des petits bouts tiennent par
petits bouts de seine
y'a pas l'idée de tenir deux heures et
demie en scène non-stop à transpirer et
une fois que la machine est lancée au
théâtre ça ne s'arrête plus c'est
vraiment chômeuse button jusqu'au bout
et c'est vraiment plus le le credo de
cette maison qui joue tous les jours de
l'année
tous les soirs le rideau se lève ici
quoi qu'il se passe
[Musique]
beaumont
c'est parti alors attention rideau
[Musique]
moi je mets trop d'affect dans les
choses donc donc heureusement que je
suis pas ici tout le temps parce que
d'un moment j'ai envie de coucher avec
tout le monde j'imagine c'est pas en fin
de jeu non mais je suis trop il faut 30
à avoir un peu de prendre l'air un peu
maman
maman maman c'est sûr que là avoir le
luxe faire les deux hommes c'est une
chance inouïe c'est évidemment que c'est
tellement enrichissant de de passer de
l'un à l'autre
[Musique]
mais bon mais parce que parce qu'on aime
les dom
maman oui quoi j'ai un peu mal à la tête
moi aussi maman tu sais quoi j'ai
retrouvé mon premier amour de quand
j'étais petit sou viana un tiens vaut à
thiais va bien je crois
alain a toujours nourri l'autre il
aurait toujours la récréation de l'autre
dès que j'ai fini une pièce pendant
longtemps répété jouer j'ai qu'une hâte
c'est d'aller sur un plateau cinéma et
vice versa juste après les robes de
cocktail
[Musique]
bat en retraite
à
bautrait et les toits
[Musique]
j'ai pas l'impression d'avoir plus
raison en faisant plein de choses
différentes que qu'un acteur qui tire
une carrière moins en moins éclectique
quand je tourne un film j'ai hâte d'être
au théâtre quand je suis au tas de
lettres de tourner un film
et quand je fais une comédie ga de
trisha brown enfin moi j'aime le théâtre
pour tous qui l'a d'extraverti de ya pas
de limite au cinéma travaille plus à
l'intérieur comme quelque chose qui
irait de dents en fait pour moi c'est
comme deux extrêmes mais encore une fois
drg jour je vous le demande avec la si
ce n'est assez de larmes d'une personne
que vous savez c'est mais je vous en
conjure par tout ce qui est le plus
capable de vous toucher coeur de tiquera
le naturalisme et le réalisme de la
parole au cinéma me nourris dont je
pense dans la vérité du théâtre mais
rien bonsoir à c'était magnifique
par contre je désolé je peux pas vous
laisser passer ce soir c'est bien
d'éviter les graves pas demain le cinéma
vous apporte une petite notoriété plus
rapide et plus évident que les pièces
superbes au magnifique on a la joie et
la chance d'interpréter à la comédie
française
c'est vrai qu'un film les gens ont
tendance à vous reconnaître assez
facilement des ratages des vues d'un tel
film
bon c'est amusant c'est flatteur mais on
n'a pas ça évidemment avec le ter il ya
toujours eu des acteurs qui faisait
l'aller retour je pense que ça vient
aussi de l'envi des acteurs ou des
propositions qu'on leur fait quand on a
un très beau rôle au théâtre où c'est
difficile d'accepter voilà de dire non
c'est pour aller au cinéma faire cinq
jours ci jouant ce qu'elle souhaite ici
c'est que quand même il ya eu des
auteurs comme victor hugo
comme molière comme racine qui ont écrit
de très beaux rôles pour les femmes
c'est pas forcément le cas au cinéma
ils se font rares les films
bah oui à des lâches camille claudel
ils sont assez rares
quand on est
jeune con à 24 ans qu'on rentre à la
comédie française comme je lé fais il ya
bientôt dix ans quel sens ça qu'est ce
qu'on vient y faire
qu'est ce qu'on vient y dire quand on y
est toujours dix ans après est ce qu'on
y reste si oui pourquoi
pour pour y faire quoi voilà c'est des
questions que je pense il faut se poser
je trouve que c'est un service que je me
rends et que je rends aussi à la à la
troupe de toujours envisager un départ
possible sous ça st si j'arrive et si je
me disais je vais rester longtemps ici
je je sais que je veux je me donnerais
encore plus de grand air que je me fais
déjà
[Musique]
pendant la convention dassault jean
revenir
un soir sur deux joue et misanthrope ici
il fait tout renaissance tour reprenait
sans cinéma on part là c'est très
confortable pas agréable et on a des
moments de jeu mais bon deux minutes par
jour de trois minutes par jour on le
souhaiterait en btcc de plus faire de
théâtre de plus avoir la sueur du
plateau pour moi la scène c'est c'est
comme une drogue
des fois j'ai besoin rouge montchaude
ont envie de jouer ce soir c'est par
rapport aux sensations très fortes que
ça procure des trois coups et puis
rentrer dans une histoire devant un
public eut rien plus beaucoup moins chez
moi le désir de jouer est très très fort
je me rends compte sait jamais il n'a
jamais diminué
j'ai eu envie de jouer tout où beaucoup
tout le temps partout
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]